15 then I was quite nervous because I
wanted to impress him but now I played
in a team with him for for so long that
I I just feel very motivated because
Magnus is a like
uh Real Sports person he wants to always
win and we see in in his game look at
this position in his his position looks
looks very very nice we can see the the
structure uh black has double pawns on
F7 and F5 and also the Knight on D6 is
very very strong Pawn on D5 also weak so
I think it's a great position are you
missing it a little bit with the team
being there there were a lot of videos
on the internet of you guys having such
a great time
I hope hope we will do the same again at
some point
and take a look at that pawn structure
he's got that extra deep on with the
double pawns on the f file this looks
like bad news the B6 Pawn is hanging so
many tactics actually you can perhaps
you pick up 90 s or is that too greedy
I think you most certainly I think you
at least have to think about it because
if you don't pick up that pawn
if white drops the night back then
Mishra could take on D4 and that's
exactly the way that you lose this
Advantage if you're the world champion
he's also up six minutes I think that's
another reason why I'm feeling very very
pessimistic for the youngest Grand
Master in the world So currently Magnus
is up a pawn right black has six pawns
white has seven Knight takes B6 is on
the board and queen B5 here is what I
think Carlson was calculating maybe the
move D5 can be played counter-attacking
Black snipe I'm not totally sure that
this is over I I don't think it's over
I mean there's some Precision that's
required here right the Knight on B6
doesn't really have a retreat Square so
you have to find a way to counter attack
you don't want to go all the way to A8
definitely going to get stopped then
Knight D4 is hanging uh that's not a
square your knight belongs in but D5 I
like that move after D5 black can at
least look at picking up that Knight on
B6 you pick up the Knight on E6 white
picks up black picks up the Rook on D1
and after Queen D1 just watch out don't
pick up the E6 Pawn with your queen
there is a background problem yeah I'll
show that on the analysis board because
Carlson with plenty of time uh is going
to take some time to think about this if
he goes D5 which I think he will abimino
has to already be thinking about whether
it's worth going for this end game as
you said not Queen takes C6 but I'm
pessimistic Tanya because Carlson can
win these In classical chess I feel like
within the confines of a gamer his
opponent is 30 seconds Queen the D6
might decide the game immediately
according to the eval bar so I be Manu
has to keep the knights on the board I
think and try to go after magnus's night
after Knight C5 maybe E6 works out for
white the Tactics get really really
crazy but Carlson has to calculate the
position like this and actually properly
evaluated because he will be down a
piece here if abimanu keeps the knights
on the board never mind it's a moot
point Carlson has made a different move
we go back to the evil part he's
refrained from D5 instead he's trying to
force the Queens off the board that's
given black I think some very decent
drawing chances after the trade
yeah you can trade and you can pick up
the default Pawn while he decides to
pick up the pawn first queen B5 shade
now the big problem for abhimanyu Mishra
is also the clock Daniel he's down to 25
seconds the Knight on D4 it's been nice
move by Magnus just sidestepping a
discover check by the night
I feel like that was a really really bad
move by Abby because it's given white a
fully sort of rectified Pawn structure
on the queen side the reason I think
he's done that he's trying to keep the
B6 Knight at Bay but he's fighting a
lost battle because his own pieces are
stuck in mud on the deep I think Carlson
he wins these games you know 99 times
out of 100 I'm not even exaggerating I
don't see Mishra holding this with 15
seconds but you never know we've seen
how good he is in acute time pressure
Rook see it is another excellent
defensive move in Hanover
and Magnus is not pleased with the fact
that he allowed abhimanyu's Rook to
escape out of this pin because if the
Knight would have moved even a rook
trades a nightborne ending would have
been completely winning but Magnus still
dominating the Rooks are alive but the
Rook enters E6 what a move pick up the
G7 Pawn E6 will fall eight seven will
fall the clock will fall the game will
fall The Rook will fall as well and the
game does indeed fall abhimanyu Mishra
suffers his first PC a loss but it's a
good person to lose to